hello friends and welcome back to game
sports continuing coverage of the
electronic triple 2016 we're almost done
it is day 49 of e3 were still alive I'm
delighted to be joined by Cliff
Bleszinski and I are young Bruce a
helluva bosque studio save every night
it feels like day 49 it's weird you've
been doing this for a long time right
then at every III ever really yeah like
when it was in Atlanta and then when
they had the weird one in santa monica
like it's not my first rodeo sir heaven
is a 20 I think we're on t2 or something
okay right guy actually the my first
convention the big one was at CES back
in the day right before they started
doing III and then III came about and
III for many years has been the super
bowl for me but it's a really weird year
hmm it's like a lot of the big names
kind of pulled out and are doing right
their own kind of event and so it's kind
of a transitional year so I don't know
if he threw the e3 bubble has burst or
whatnot it's weird yeah cuz you guys
were still involved in judges week right
yeah I what I was hearing for a lot of
people was like judges week at least
from the press I just felt way more
scale down oh absolutely would did you
feel that like is it was that a worry
for you at all or was actually kind of
better in a way it's better for us
because you know we're still happy to
participate in three because you know we
want to promote you know lawbreakers as
much as possible and you know when
certain large entities pull out or they
know like blizzard you know isn't even
here right right so it's like hey you
know we have more opportunity for more
people to you know have eyeballs on our
game yeah actually have a you know look
at it leave a really cool tool is better
now this offside Evander was like a
really cool event people just you could
get out and and give it a little of
tired and restless gorgeous modern house
in Venice and basically had you know the
555 set up all the journalists came out
just messed each other up and with the
thing about the game and it's when
people get hands on with it they see
right makes it unique they see that it's
a blast they see that yeah it's a
first-person character based shooter but
we have our own unique take on it yeah
so I remember the you had a similar sort
of thing at PAX as well last year where
you were like hey this is the game one
weekend we've got this place come over
okay it's especially refreshing for our
tienen I you know he worked on kill zone
for years I'm in like years four years
and you're you'd always show up at e3
with your perfectly scripted demo or the
the tower falls the bridge collapses the
monster brother are and you know go to
logo in the crowd lose their their crap
right those are usually you know how
together with like duct tape and Bubba
and band-aids right and it's usually one
of those things you spent like three
months you know killing the team just to
impress everybody and now we're at the
point were like this is the game now no
fire it up play it let us know what you
think but then that must be a sort of
another element of nerves because you're
basically handing over something that
isn't finished well that's the thing is
the game has a bit of a learning curve
you know or you know if the abilities on
QE you know we have blind firing using
control we have different mobility with
shift you know different types of double
jumps and things like that there is a
little bit of a learning curve so the
more of a learning curve there is though
the more the more depth there is so for
the first play session in the half or so
people kind of fumble a little bit right
by the time they start getting you know
their legs in the game it winds up being
like second nature you know people wind
up really learning how to play the
different type of classes we have the
game so i guess the people we're talking
to people who won't be able to get a
chance to get hands on themselves so
what is it that feels different about
lawbreakers well so first and foremost
it's the tone you know there's this
thing that happens in a post League of
Legends world a lot of these games you
know MOBAs and some of these characters
shooters they they look like bubblegummy
little kind of candy like you know it's
it's totally cool and I like a lot of
those games but it's not the kind of
game I want to make you know we want to
make something that's a little bit more
quitting Tarantino asked you know with
assassins and and ex-cons de-age and
Sulli have oh my god a little bit of
blood in the game and then as well as
well as that also have a you know the
idea of playing with gravity you know
and there's so many things that have
happened throughout my life that have
led to this moment from taking a zero g
flight to reading the Leviathan wakes
the idea of like what happens if you
have a low gravity or zero-g environment
and you fire a weapon right well you go
the opposite direction so imagine you
can kind of steer yourself through
gravity zones by firing a rocket
launcher or your kind of sci-fi assault
rifle right what happens if you fire it
behind you and you're trying to take the
objective to get to your base well
occasionally once in a blue moon you
might actually get a blind fire kill at
which point you feel like ash vs. Evil
Dead you're like whoo-hoo that was good
and so what we're going for is a game
that has lots of verbs that leads to
lots of moments infinite watch ability
and human types that really build to
kind of a climax so it's not just like
your traditional dominations as we're
showing turf war here at e3 in our Santa
Monica map where it's like you know you
capture point you're like okay I'm just
going to look at my watch on my phone
now and wait for you know us to accrue
points once you have a point the point
closes go to the next point once all
three points are captured 36 seconds of
team deathmatch
repeat okay but that's the teller said
that before yeah and it I guess an
interesting thing about it and you know
apologies in advance for making the
references other games but a lot of
other games are sticking to very
traditional modes you guys are actually
tearing up well that actually you know
bugs me because you know I've ranted on
social media about this it's like when
you spend time putting features in your
game you think you need because other
games have them you're making the same
thing other games have the same crap and
so you know you look at how a mobile
works like that that game types a
collection of very unique things coming
together it's kind of like RTS elements
people didn't know that before
counter-strike and counter-strike go
it's one of the most airtight unique
game types the whole bomb game type of
point a and point B did not exist before
counter-strike made it gamers are smart
they will learn and if they don't learn
somebody out there who's ambitious will
stream it or put it on YouTube right I'm
figure it out or put it on reddit right
the antigrav stuff is really interesting
because I mean what you're basically
essentially doing is sort of like Reid
teaching people because like we're used
to antigrav I mean Morpheus in Unreal
Tournament like you that were used to
antigrav the showing your age of that I
know yeah but you should have heard
David K just say when I taught taught a
conversation about bloody Omicron the
Nomad so you should yeah I know yeah
true actually we talked about that was
it was very sweet and but yeah sorry you
know antigrav levels were sort of used
to that it's a you know it's so what
you're essentially doing is you surfing
what people think about those big thing
man to remember is you know we're a
little bit older right the younger
generation doesn't remember ziggurat
vertigo and Morpheus right no because
you have your average call duty kid
who's like 16 17 you know call duties
great they're doing some space levels
now and what not and you know we can
take what was in the past and
reintroduce it kind of like with a new
twist and it seems fresh to everybody
you know the latest called a tease
that's like it's got double jump and
wall running it's like dude that what is
this like she doesn't work yeah yeah you
know and so these features seem new and
so time is a flat circle it's like
fashion you know I'm out shopping with
my wife and I see like young women
wearing these like high-waisted
acid-wash jeans I'm like am I in high
school it's like flannels back what the
hell's going on everything is sick with
cyclical yeah history repeating I mean
the second games like over watching it's
like Oh action quick okay right that's
helpful to the viewer okay yeah well
that's the whole point is like you know
we made a game that I believe is very
watchable all right you know like it
important is that like it's funny it's
definitely important and the number one
question I'm always asked by every
is this game gonna be the eSport yeah
and it's like I would love for nothing
more than for people to fight for
millions of dollars in this game but you
can't force it what you can do is start
with a game that's washable that creates
animated gifts youtube moments no
blindfire kill highlight reels and drama
modes and then you know hopefully the
sweaty palms will come out of that maybe
eventually make the leap all right you
know and I think what's what's cool
what's happening you said you know we've
been playing the game all along right
we're playing at multiple times a day
and you know every time still we have
matches that ends in like this crescendo
there's a point that goes back and forth
it's crazy and there's a lot of
hollering etc we even see that here at
people play the game for the first time
and it ends in like in this massive
excitement people like screaming and all
that time like wow that's cool right
I've not seen that a lot in my previous
games for for a long time so that's like
this excitement hopefully that radiates
out when people start streaming this
gnome right and playing it themselves
and you know by by themselves on the
college and we've been in development
for a while and one of the things we've
learned that the phrase already on like
CDs to make the devs eat their own dog
food right you know every day we're
playing the game and if I come to work
and the game is broken and we can't play
the game that day he did I get very
upset all right it's like you need to
continue to play the game every day and
fine tune it and you know we're gonna do
our best job of balancing the game
internally but that we're only 65 people
yeah yeah when we open the game up to
65,000 people are going to find bubs to
find balance issues they're gonna find
you know exploit excellent they're gonna
five parts of the map we didn't know
they could even get to and you know and
so what we're doing with the game you
know going into alpha this weekend on
the 18th preloading on steam on the 16th
as the fact of the matter is come play
the game with us for free get a key on
law breakers calm and break the game
with us you know will be online with you
I'm not gonna pull punches if I see you
online i'm going to mess you up because
i just i can't help it and the other
thing is people get so good at the game
within a few weeks that I need that
brief period to feel good oh yeah you
know get my team annihilation to get my
double kills because you know they get
the you know the young kids have really
really good reaction time you know the
keyboard and mouse players are so good
you play CS co and they're so amazingly
good at the dash depressing the second
they get that off you better have that
smoke anyway what we want to make a game
that has strats you know where people
actually have to like pay attention and
like kind of jockey for position and end
with drama as we should be set so talk
about that mastery then I guess because
you're showing it to bunch of press
people who are basically having a couple
of games and they're like they probably
are pretty shitty after like two or
three games then it's obviously the
opposite end of that spectrum where you
guys where you've got like 65 on people
who are paying it all the time and so
what what what others like the mastery
is it is it like individual characters
you're sort of getting used to is it's
just the overall well it really a little
bit and play style right I see a lot of
these character based shooters that are
so rock paper scissors hmm then if you
select your character classes are
delicious by the way really yeah quite
good all right come around the corner
and you select the class that you spawn
with you see the other class it's like I
can't even engage with that class
because they told the rock paper scissor
me right yeah go the other way in this
game no matter what class you play as if
you're good and you master that class
you can ruin the other team and so it's
one of those things like we just want
everybody to have a chance depending on
their play style if you like to be you
know nimble and use a grappling hook and
use you know melee weapons you can play
as Hallion in consuming if you like
rocket launchers and splash damage you
can play as Chronos a bomb show so it's
basically play your way and then don't
force the players to select a class as
you know there's this thing that's
happened with certain games that's
bleeding over in certain first-person
shooters where it's like oh no there's
two medics in the server so you can't be
a medic right you know what screw you I
want to be this class like you can't
tell me what to do so what we have to do
balance wise is if they're the team
decides to stack as the heavies is
Chronos and bomb show all rocket
launchers doubling in size and shooting
lightning from their hands were like
okay we have to figure out a way to
balance that or allow the other team to
counter that right this is you know it's
on us as game designers to figure this
out and we need you know the community
in the Alpha to help us work through
this so you're like taking the burden
away from the players to like figure out
the chess pieces yeah that battle all
right power the players yeah thinking of
the interesting thing is that we've been
playing a game all this time right and
then you know you still see people doing
this new stuff right so friends we have
this assassin glass with with this
elastic type grappling hook that you can
control and we could see people do is
they swing around to the map entirely
but then they also have double jump or
shift right that kind of stuff but they
figured out that again reset double jump
by disgracing rice geology so they can
really swing around entirety of the map
be like a couple grapple silver energy
left and then killed team the other team
like like close to their base and that
kind of stuff they see this really cool
emergent things happening and didn't
think you know that the other main thing
is that you know we've trained people so
much in the past generation of shooters
on consoles that everything is
horizontal that people are only scanning
left to right and you know they start
playing
you see them doing that right they don't
look up and then they started you know
and then it's up with like 10 minutes in
15 mins in this clicks and they and they
start moving up and then then you
realize well actually did the battles
the good battles are probably in the air
yeah right so they go up and we have all
these classes that can move vertically
and be effective vertically so that
that's also really cool and fresh though
it's interesting stocks are the exam the
game a little kind of shakes out to be
like Kill Bill by wave crouching tiger
hidden dragon by wave the inception how
I fight scene by wave the matrix let's
drop 15 pop culture reference nice yeah
it's just you know I'm airheads were
delicious we joke its vertical violence
right like I like alliteration but it's
one of those things like when i see you
know the two characters with the swords
dueling midair and zero g or people like
blind fire and you know through the zero
g zone and stomping in and the idea is
like i used to say we know what's more
important the story of the game or the
gameplay is the story of the gameplay
it's like being able to describe the
fact that i came in the base i had my
lightning hands then my assassin came in
and used her ultimate and messed up the
whole team we grabbed the battery took
it back two seconds left we won and it's
like oh my god that's amazing and that's
what you know yields interesting moments
and that's what I've learned from like
you know watching american football in
particular is the fact that you know the
last four minutes of american football
game three-quarters of the time it can
go any either way and that's one of the
things you know one of the streamers was
talking to yesterday who played our game
they're like in the battery mode you
know it's possible if one team and wins
and kicks but for ninety-nine percent of
the time the other team in the last few
seconds can still grab the battery and
make you know what that's called the
Hail Mary yeah they pull that off that's
good and you do not want a game type
where you know halfway through a
15-minute matched over it's clearly over
here's what happens then everyone leaves
the server you always want that that
that chance that slim chance the other
team could actually pull through because
that's that that sense of hope it's the
old Yogi Berra saying it ain't over till
it's over yeah and that underdog victory
is even more satisfying the other one
and so obviously both of you have worked
on you know some story first person
shooter franchises and when you're
tackling law breakers were you pulling
inspiration from those games from older
games or were you doing the whole I'm
actually just looking at general media
and I want to create something
completely new yeah I mean I think you
know him having worked on kills only
having worked on gears which were great
successful huge franchise I was talking
more about unreal tournament though that
tears is good too well thank you on your
age again um there's a new one from epic
looks good yeah my whole point is you
know
we're at this point in our careers where
we've learned what works and doesn't
work from prior games we've worked on
yeah and you know you look at a lot of
these studios and what they do is they
build this mega campaign and then they
phone in the multiplayer because it's
like you know some other contractor just
does it for them and then you're sitting
here in they put it out on disk and it's
like you just made a campaign rental
we're going to buy that game burn
through it over the weekend and trade it
in because you're multiplayers light his
old joke that REM was saying is like
dude why don't you contract out the
single player yeah and like focus on the
multiplayer is your core and you know he
was working on battlefield a TA it's
like you know seventy-five percent of
the budget is on this campaign and right
water that comes out of this Hollywood
envy that this business has with like oh
it's so cinematic and you know and act 3
you know the characters new bruises
partner does and everyone's gonna cry
you know your game or killed thousands
of people and say I'm kind of over that
made it chest hair and all that kind of
stuff yeah I think also the interesting
thing and we both have it right so you
know me with kills on trying to push the
PlayStation right best graphical
fidelity right like you know we run 30
frames a second because we have like
twice to the the frame time to make the
graphics look awesome right and then
same thing with gears or like a look at
what the consoles can do but now we
don't have to do that right you don't
sell anything Rosell engines rights no
no platform etc and now we're like it
okay but I gave the black gameplay so
you know the game runs it like unbounded
frame rate when you're showing it like I
lat 40 frames a second people like this
is so smooth is so nice like super low
latency and you know super fast servers
and that all kind of helps at gameplay
and then you know I think it still looks
awesome right the game so we're not
making that many concessions right on
art but you know we do make them every
down there because here the arts are
like yeah we want to do that and I can
you know because I will you know but
also they these are your decisions to
make it's not like you've got somebody
else breathing under your jacket you
know who's having to sell consoles or
you know when I was in epicatechin sell
the engine right it's like oh we have
this new water effect that's gonna look
amazing looking out for refraction the
walls and everything in a more water
level bingo that's exactly how it was
right and like this amazing fire stuff
now I need a guy with a flamethrower
great so now with that game it's like
she's turned me into like the biggest
framerate junkie like it drops below 100
I just want to throw my keyboard out the
window and and so we as a result we've
made a game
where it's you know 50 200 milliseconds
can make the world of a difference all
right so you know you need a decent rig
to run it you know we're going to
continue to optimize going to you know
because when you put a game out on pc as
we are you know you wanted to run it as
many pieces as possible you know that's
really your install base that's your
potential customers that said you know i
think we look great but we also are
smooth as butter that's one of those
things like when I come into the office
and I see him you know taking his iphone
using a super slo-mo filming it and he's
like clicking in the mouse to see what
the latency is between the mouse
clicking and the weapons firing like
that's the level you need to be at well
no in 2016 and beyond especially if
you're eventually going to hopefully
somewhere to way down the line make leap
to any sport right I have to ask you so
what's the both of you worked on storied
franchises both of your prospective
previous employees working on new
versions of old games or amores I've
completely new ip's or whatever horizon
awesome what's it like you seeing that
sort of stuff all the ways like to
describe it it's like you know with
Microsoft doing a Gears game with
epoch-making you games it's like imagine
splitting with an ex and it's still
amicable you're like you know what right
yeah isn't working go on do your thing
and then you hear they're getting like
married remarried yeah you're like you
know what your son seems nice I hope
they're not better-looking the miracle
at me yeah i 100% and so you know i saw
the new gears demo really good look
really cool but I told rod fergusson I
have notes what a better Eisen like a
bunch of your ex-colleagues also I'm
gorillas biggest fan right still right I
founded a company you know yeah I'm hang
out with him tonight try to the the the
the guy that designed all the rowboats
Roy you know it was my first employee
ever hired oh really 90 solo bots were
awesome from the royalties of Jessica
Rabbit I'd I hired him and I hire
detected guys and all that kind of stuff
you were so you know I i was just
playing the game and and and it looks
freaking amazing and i hope hope they
pull off the open rolls and a question
all that but i figure there's a lot more
and more coming there that's that's
that's going to be super exciting you
know i think it's it's you know for me
it was you know I think it'll speech
like 2010 really okay game has been in
development for like six six years right
and that's just crazy right and
sometimes you need to take that time to
build like these massive new things
right and we are trying to you know by
just focusing right you're not doing
single-player we're not doing facial
animations right
just doing multiplayer etc know and we
can do something really fast right in a
year after we started with lice five
people we have the game playing and yeah
well I'm seeing you guys at pacsun like
it's there it's like oh holy [ __ ] okay
hashtag me with unreal right I think
horizon looks amazing that it looks like
Egret versus the soit's yeah I like to
describe the damn game before I let you
guys go and have you I need to ask as
well just because you're both like
lauded and the designers of various
first-person shooter games have you
played not less overwatch actually
interested have you made doom fantastic
campaign right yeah I mean yeah do you
think they intentionally scuff the
multiplayer because they had that quake
thing look man oh god I I criticize my
friends at it'd and Microsoft and
everything because I care like Nintendo
cuz I care I was called the kind of boys
a child my thing about the new it and I
knew I saw this my wife used to work at
eight software she was a bill manager
back in the day at seven years ago she
was working on rage when I first started
writing or and went on and I rage came
out in great campaign absolutely
stunning like some weird like pseudo Mad
Max car racing mario kart multiplayer
yeah this is its software this is the
company that [ __ ] invented deathmatch
like you better deliver some awesome
death match and I played the early alpha
of the do multiplayer and it wasn't bad
but after 30 minutes I'm like okay I get
the idea yeah you know you can turn it
into a demon like no I want to be
shooting rocket launchers and people in
my my death matching dude right so the
campaign had so much love and I think
machine games worked on that you know
it's just critical oh yeah because ended
at the mall you yeah that's the whole
thing is you know like it and then I
think it's actually acknowledged that
they're taking it in house but you know
business-wise I'm like that might be too
little too late guys you know like you
should have you know done that initially
and like again you know when you put out
a disk based game people just trading
games now right there so by the time you
know the multiplayer gets you know
updated for them people may have moved
on to the next Call of Duty or maybe
lawbreakers or god knows what yeah I'll
tell you man that campaign is just its
crunchy its the weapons are amazing the
levels looks so good and they did such a
good job of balancing you know when
you're inside kind of the claustrophobic
basis to kind of being on the the
Martian surface in particle effects all
of its it's just really really good it's
real good time for first-person shooters
and you guys are coming out with one
real soon when can people get on the
Alpha for lawbreakers on the 18th this
weekend also has saturday and sunday
well you know it's closed off we go to
lawbreakers calm sign up
distributed a bunch of keys if you see
us at e3 my wife and I are handing out
the indices are Daniel a little cards
the key on it it's on steam enter the
code hop online you know it's got a
little bit of a learning curve we're
starting with one map one mode grandview
the Grand Canyon map as well as the
capture the battery mode overcharge and
then in early July the promenade map and
tours coming online and more and more
stuff's going to keep happening until we
get to the point where you flip a switch
and actually say hey you know we'd like
to keep the studio going if you'd like
to give us a few bucks right and that'll
probably be 20 17 I'm guessing no late
2016 oh really what happened yep you
guys have a large price point somewhere
between twenty to forty dollars haven't
determined that yet you know we're not
gonna make a multiplayer only game and
ask you for 60 bucks and that's [ __ ]
cool beans cliff Kaczynski our John the
boose a pleasure add to talk to you both
from buskey studios best of luck with
the rest of it and yeah you can keep
those airheads you permission you've
earned them we'll be back in just a
minute folks or a bit of a shifting
gears here from first person to hot
strategy games we got hit awards to
coming up in a little bit but first of
all dawn dawn of war three [ __ ] few
minutes
you